well I'm joined now rejoined in fact my
guest I had last night Fred Hagan who
was on board the last two Titan missions
and those two of the people on board
Stockton rush and Paul Henry najalay
well uh Fred I'm really sad to speak to
you again
now that we know the news which I think
we both probably feared yesterday we
didn't want to say that very sadly
everyone on board has lost their lives
what is your reaction to what we just
heard
what fears as you can imagine sitting
here listening to this press conference
while waiting to talk to you is uh
made this much more difficult than I
anticipated
and
I I can only say that
the world has lost two radiant points of
Life of light with
Stockton and pH
and as we talked yesterday
these men were great men who tried
greatly and risked everything
and I want direct to be what Teddy Russ
felt said
the credit belongs to the man who was
actually in the arena
whose face is marked by dust and sweat
and blood in his strides value errors
who come short again and again because
there is no effort without Aaron's
shortcoming but who does actually strive
to do the Deeds who knows great
enthusiasms
the great devotions who spends himself
in a worthy cross
who at the best knows in the end the
Triumph of I achievement excuse me and
who at the worst if he fails at least
fails while daring greatly
so the display shall never be
with those cold and timid Souls who know
neither victory
in order to feed them that to me
is the true epitaph
to stop from Rush and pH nor Soleil and
their Companions and I'm very sorry I
just
it it was just devastating sitting here
listening to the realization of what we
all feared and then trying to express my
feelings moments later I apologize Fred
there's no apology obviously needed at
all I know from my our conversation
yesterday how personally moved you've
been by this the rest of the world has
watched on in sort of mounting horror as
this story has unraveled for you it was
incredibly personal you've been on this
vessel you've been on the last two
Titanic missions in 2021 and 22 with Dr
Rush with your friend pH he'd been down
to that wreckage 30 odd times I think
and brought back so many extraordinary
things for the world to see it was a
genuine historian in that sense we're
looking at a picture of of you all now
um it's a desperately sad time for you
and for everyone who knew them their
friends their families everyone and it's
a sad time I think for the world to look
on and see people who ultimately as I I
said yesterday I got very angry about
the reaction
from certain people about the fact that
they were wealthy people paying to go
down there and so on it to me they were
Intrepid explorers doesn't matter how
much money you have they're Intrepid
explorers and some are paid to be there
and some were being paid to be there
makes the difference that the goal was
to go down and find
new information which could shed light
on one of the great tragedies of the
history of this planet which was the the
sinking of the Titanic and I commend
them for the courage that it took to do
that and I think that their death is an
absolute tragedy but they should be
remembered as Heroes who who went down
there I wouldn't go down there I mean I
I admire you for doing it you know it's
an extraordinary thing to want to do
and peers I'd like to say that
right now at this point in time
the death toll from the Titanic tragedy
has risen from 1517.
to 1522 and may God Rest their souls
yeah I mean it is an eerie thing isn't
it when you think about the Titanic and
the huge death loss as you say and the
fact that we're going down there to see
there and have now lost their lives it
was a very poignant interview actually
with the older sister of shazada Darwood
who said uh she felt absolutely
heartbroken that both her brother and of
course her nephews only 19 is a student
at strathclyde University
um and this is asthma Darwin who was the
aunt of that young boy and the sister of
of his father on board as well I feel
like I've been caught in a really bad
film she said with a countdown but you
didn't know what you're counting down to
I've personally found it incredibly
difficult to breathe thinking of them
she then said that her nephew didn't
want to go on the uh on the submersible
but agreed to take part because it was
important to his father a lifelong
Titanic obsessive uh the Solomon she
said wasn't very up for it and was
terrified explaining the 19 year old had
expressed his concerns on the Family
remember but that is of course part of I
guess the adventure and yes it's ended
it's ended in appalling circumstances
it's cost that young man his life but
his father obviously was enthralled by
the history of this and wanted to be
part of that history to go down there
and to explore and again I say I think
it's a heroic and Noble thing to do that
kind of thing most people don't get the
chance to do it and don't have the
inclination to do it
most people live lives of quiet
desperation and these men lived large
they realize their dreams they pursued
them and they should be celebrated
it's been revealed by the Coast Guard it
doesn't appear to be any connection
between the underwater banging noises
that were identified yesterday coming
every 30 minutes and the location of
where this debris was found so they seem
to be same it doesn't appear to be any
connection there does that suggest to
you Fred that this catastrophic
implosion may have happened quite
quickly after they went down what would
be your reading of this
well clearly it happened very quickly I
was originally critical
of the fact that the those in command
did not allow the Brits to immediately
mobilize the Magellan and obviously that
was because they'd heard a seismic event
and they interpreted it as a
catastrophic failure and then those
noises were heard and there was a change
of heart the French came last night they
showed up on site for their beloved pH
and you know I believe that the Magellan
was finally mobilized and that was as a
result of hearing those knocking noises
but yes at this point uh clearly there
was a catastrophic failure on The
Descent and the and while we're all
devastated by the loss of these
wonderful human beings at the same time
there's another little part of me that
that is relieved that they have not
spent the last several days dying slowly
and the most horrific nightmarish
condition yes I think that's absolutely
right uh it was from what I've read when
this kind of implosion occurs it
literally takes milliseconds and nobody
on board would even be aware of it
um it's it is catastrophic and instant
that is correct and at least they were
spared any suffering and that is some
solace
to ph's daughter and to the families to
Stockton's Widow Wendy and to all the
others I didn't know the other
passengers but it is a small solace
you know you talk about pH it's
extraordinary man he served in the
French Navy for 25 years he was known as
Titanic's greatest Explorer according to
his biography he was widely considered
the leading Authority on the Titanic
shipwreck
um what was he like as a man Fred
well you would never have known that he
was the preeminent deep diving expert on
Earth you know he was a consummate
professional
but you would sit down with him and he
would be just as warm and relaxed as as
your oldest friend and as someone else
said whether he was just as comfortable
in the deck of the ship than a tornado
as he was sitting in a Parisian Cafe I
mean that was very true and and that was
pH he was very down to earth he was both
incredibly accomplished and Incredibly
humble
the
you've been on this you've been on the
same missions did you have moments Fred
were you felt unnerved scared even I
mean how intimidating is the experience
of doing this kind of Journey
it can be very intimidating
uh
pH would would always be calm and and
you know there are some people that are
just calm under stress and I like to
think I'm one of them there were a few
moments we when we got kind of the
currents pulled us into the ship and we
were momentarily entangled and I I know
that others on the sub were
maybe more on nerved than you know and
they wanted to immediately Ascend for my
part uh you know we I was wanted I
wanted to see the stern and one of the
experiences I had this years we went all
around the bow and explored it and I
wanted to go to the stern on the Saint I
want to be the first person to see both
pieces on the same deck and we tried and
the when we got back Wendy and Stockton
were both incredulous and saying what on
Earth were you doing why were you trying
to get to the stern and of course I was
blamed for the our perseverance so I'm
not sure if I answered your question or
addressed it but yes there were moments
but they did not in any way
diminish my appetite to experience
the Titanic and experience this
wonderful adventure with with ph and
Marshall Lane I always treasure that
event and always treasure his friendship
we have a statement just in from the
British foreign secretary James
cleverley tragic news that those on the
Titan submersible including three
British citizens have been lost
following an international search
operation the UK government is closely
supporting the families affected and
expresses our deepest condolences
um Stockton Rush inevitably I guess as
the CEO and founder of Ocean Gate he's
come under in the last few days a lot of
criticism along with the company uh for
maybe cutting corners and not doing
enough
um to make the Titan properly secure for
this kind of mission
you know it's it I I don't think we
should labor that point now that he's so
sadly lost his life but what is your
response Fred to that particular
criticism that it wasn't really ready to
do this kind of thing
the only criminal act
was the failure of governments to
properly fund science and deep water
exploration
what Stockton did was to pursue Cutting
Edge technology to take human beings
into a realm where they've never gone
before
you know you've had previously you had
government funded submersibles maybe
that whole one or two people that have
gone that deep you've never had anyone
try to democratize the deaths trying to
take Humanity where it never belonged
and was never able to access and I I
look at it kind of like the original
Flyers as I mentioned previously the
Wright brothers took off and left the
Surly Bonds of Earth do you know how
many people died trying to make Aviation
safe and and where anybody could
participate safely they died by the
hundreds by the scores and they gave
their lives trying to you know stretch
the envelope to exceed expectations to
go further and farther and faster and
Stockton was doing that he was doing it
in the depths of the ocean which is the
great Frontier on Earth the last
unexplored region of Earth which is so
critical to our own future and critical
to the preservation of Life on her and
hey Miss holiday and I'll just
I'll just add that a lot of the
criticism that's mounting up I mean I I
hear things I've heard I can't tell how
many times I've heard about the joystick
you know it's a video game joystick and
it's like uh that's funny and people
laugh and they make fun of it well
that's the difference between a
government-funded project and a
brilliant entrepreneur who is trying to
push boundaries the government
would have spent tens of millions of
dollars designing a joystick that would
have worked perfectly and brilliantly
Stockton Rush was able to find a
joystick that worked just as efficiently
by using a video game controller and one
thing I know beyond any doubt is
whatever happened to that submersible it
had nothing to do with the video game
controller
Fred I'm so sorry that this this has
ended the way it has few or two great
friends it's a very sad day I think for
everyone who's ever been down on that
expedition to the Titanic and to lose
people who've so experienced so attached
to that must be a huge loss to you both
professionally I guess and also
obviously personally and I really
appreciate you joining me so soon after
that news was broken
thank you peers and I'll say again thank
you so much for your attitude and for
your gracious handling of this tragedy a
deeply deeply appreciate it and I know
the family does too well thank you Fred
and I I mean it I'm sincere about that I
think these people are heroic when they
do this kind of thing and to attack
people attack them because of how much
money they may have is completely
missing the point to me uh Fred Hagan
thank you very much indeed
thank you well just to recap for viewers
who are tuning in the very sad breaking
news that the Titan submersible which
had been missing for three days down
near the wreckage of the Titanic sadly
so it's now transpired suffered a
catastrophic implosion we don't know
exactly when that happened but debris
from The Vessel was discovered at about
2 30 p.m UK time this afternoon uh just
before 9 A.M eastern time in America uh
they discovered a series of items from
the debris which were identifiable as
coming from the Titan including a nose
cone the front end of the pressure Hull
the back end of the pressure Hull which
made it clear this was indeed the
missing vessel and very sadly that also
meant that all five of the people on
board had lost their lives so a very sad
end to a story which has gripped the
world